hello everyone welcome to simulation we
are currently at the blockchain for
social justice conference we have
partnered up with them to conduct some
interviews on what is a very important
conversation around both social justice
and blockchain technology and we are
currently sitting down with Cheryl Davis
hi thanks for coming on the show thanks
for having me I'm excited to be here you
greatly appreciate it yeah thank you my
pleasure so you are the executive
director of the San Fran school Human
Rights Commission that is correct
HRC HRC sometimes confused with Hillary
Rodham Clinton sometimes confused with
Housing Rights Committee so sometimes
two reviews with Human Rights Campaign
but where the Human Rights Commission
and tell us a bit about your path that
got you to where you are today alright
so I actually started as a kindergarten
teacher I was a kindergarten teacher in
an all-boys school in Pacific Heights in
San Francisco but I was living in the
Western Addition Fillmore area of San
Francisco so not far from each other but
working in private school living in a
community that was kind of surrounded by
public and subsidized housing there was
a police station a couple blocks over
and so when I would walk home from work
I could literally see how the blocks
would start to change the closer I got
to home and so I started doing some
volunteer work in the Western Addition
where I live to kind of absolve myself
from the guilt from you know working in
a school with more affluent children
when I knew that there was a need in the
neighborhood I lived in let's let's
visualize this for people that aren't so
familiar with this because we're talking
Western Addition to Pacific Heights in
San Francisco is what a mile 20 minute
walk yeah 20 minute walk Dean 20 minute
walk and along that walk the
socioeconomic status goes from less than
$100,000 per family to multi-million
dollar per family yeah and so the change
of people having a apartment two people
owning a vast home and
up on the hillside overlooking the bay
versus down yeah in the city this is a
very interesting you see this every
single day as you go and teach the
kindergarten class and come back right I
mean you could see the difference even
from if I was thinking about it in terms
of stores retail or in terms of food
stores yeah I think still so when I get
from when I start at the top you know
I'm seeing more high-end you know $20
for a hamburger and then when I get
closer to home it's Burger King right or
the I remember going in the store one
time and not frequented a couple of
stores I bought some stuff they're
always on sale I show today but you know
like a dress for $300 and then I get
close to home and there's a goodwill
that does the store that's there so just
you can literally see block by block how
things go they start to change yeah yeah
so I I worked in Pacific Heights I
started volunteering in the Western
Addition volunteered at a couple of
different community centers one of which
was the african-american art and culture
complex where are now mayor-elect was
working did some volunteer work with her
and was asked to help develop out the
summer program for that community center
and so the program that I worked on for
that community center the district 5
supervisor came to that event and said
this is really great it's awesome we've
got quite a few community that typically
aren't engaged in this space would you
really help me would love for you to
come work in my office helped me build
out my community relations build up the
work with the constituents while someone
was out on paternity leave so I went and
worked in the district 5 supervisor for
a few months and then there was a
program similar to the work that I was
doing in the supervisors office that was
going to launch in the public defender's
office and I was encouraged to apply for
that job went to the public defender's
office applied for this job to develop a
program that was focused on building
partnerships between community based
organizations city agencies community
stakeholders and that was around 2006
and I launched a program called mo magic
mo because the West
tradition used to be known as the
fillmore of the mo the mo and and the
community wanted to call it mo magic
magic stood for what the public
defender's office called mobilization of
adolescent growth in our community so it
was focused on how do we support young
people how do we create pathways good
and pipelines out of poverty but also to
avoid prison and incarceration yes so I
did that for 10 years what an important
combination both the pipeline for
prosperity and career success and
happiness but also away from the prison
system exactly yeah
exactly and so were those pipelines just
out of curiosity was a series of
shootings in the neighborhood and that
really galvanized the community to say
what are we going to do if this is
happening and we're not at summer yet so
let's really be intentional about what
we're doing for our young people and
that forced the service providers to
come together and we started a series of
things like mid-tour series where we
started then taking young people from
the Western Addition to visit tech
companies to meet with people who were
in the industry to think about that as a
career opportunity to be able to
envision themselves in that space you
see you can be it exactly right and then
we also started to say like let's do
some training and workshops that do
hands-on so that they're learning this
right so that by the time they graduate
from high school they can consider
pathways and have a more concrete of the
idea of it so that was one another was
family engagement around literacy so we
started I started this having come from
being a teacher books and literacy and
were really important to me so we
started buying books for all the service
providers that were offering summer
programs and then that has since grown
to actually doing curriculum because we
had a lot of people say look we're a rec
center kids come here they play ball you
what do you want us to do with these
books so then we get the books and say
this is what parents can do this is what
service providers can do this is what
young people can do and started getting
books like there's a book called ADA
Twist
the scientist which has an
african-american girl as the the lead in
the book and talks about like her
experimentation and all the stuff she
does as a scientist there's another one
called Iggy Peck the architect which is
about a kid who loves to build with like
diapers and pancakes and again just this
idea of stem so infusing that and saying
playing with LEGOs is stem right just
being getting to have those
conversations yeah and then another one
is just this overall internship program
so those were kind of critical like how
do we build up the service providers
that are working in this community how
do we give them the resources to do this
work and then how do we build up the
young people so that was kind of at the
heart of it and then it was simple
things that we take for granted where we
raised money to take every kid in the
neighborhood to Great America or to
Santa Cruz so it literally ten bus loads
of kids at one time 700 kids from the
neighborhood going to those places so we
were building community we were building
the village because Boys and Girls Club
knew kids from the YMCA the YMCA knew
the public housing kids everybody on a
bus together spending the day in
community which is now grown to every
Wednesday during the summer all 700 of
those kids from around the neighborhood
come together and do some activity
throughout the city so from that I was
asked to run a community center and was
doing the community center work and then
started serving on the Human Rights
Commission and then from there when the
director of Human Rights Commission left
I was asked to go into that space while
the city looked for a new director and
then ultimately was asked to stay in
that position all the variables that go
into
socioeconomic status and trying to help
people it's you yeah and especially when
you figure things out like mentorship
like building the community together a
seen it being it traveling to places
like Santa Cruz getting the kids out and
by the ocean and getting a little bit in
nature
and being able to go on that field trip
together fundraising for that purpose
fundraising for the purpose of visiting
tech centers we've been fortunate I mean
we've done the internship program has
grown so now it's like 150 kids every
summer that are 14 to 24 with an
additional 30 students who actually
college age students who lead these
cohorts awesome and last year we were
able to take a group to Hong Kong to
talk about like the work that they did
they presented at a research conference
Stanford just did a study on the program
and just really looked at the impact
that being engaged has on the trajectory
yeah young people and doing it earlier
changes how they see themselves yes but
it also changes how others see them it's
interesting because we take what
ordinarily folks would think of as the
worst kid or not not the best or not the
most academic and engage with them over
the summer and if they into the summer
people will say well you picked the
cream of the crop but I'll be like they
were the cream of the crop but maybe
people didn't see that initially you
know the kids have developed apps for
the police department that they thought
would help with folks who were afraid to
tell because they thought they would be
thought of as a snitch so they've
developed apps with the the police
department they developed the social
media for the police to try and improve
community and police relations so it's
also been this tool to address community
safety but at the same time helping them
develop their skills whoa yeah yeah the
the idea of getting the skills and then
seeing how they build what they build
with the skills and their communities
yeah I can't fully wrap my head around
it because I haven't lived there and I
really want to try and wrap my head
around it as best as possible and
immerse myself in the shoes of people
behind their eyes of what it's like to
to not have the resources and tools
needed in order to prosper to not be
able to have the opportunities needed to
see people in the positions that you get
excited about
and then go and and strive to build
something so this passion for social
justice where what what part of you like
where what part of your values does it
really ring so I you know when I started
working I did an internship and the
school that I ended up teaching in and
it was the first job I had that I wasn't
like what is the day gonna be over right
like that when I looked at the clock and
it was the end of the day I was like
this is amazing
so I took the job but then when I
started to come face to face with the
realities of where I was working versus
where I was living I was like I've got
to do something and I think that was
embedded in my lived experience of
having moved around a lot I went to like
eight different schools between
kindergarten and 12th grade and having
to always be the new person or having to
always try and prove who I was or
knowing that in some of the communities
where I went to school that I was
treated better or seen differently
because of my family makeup or because
of what I had access to and I think
something triggered when I started
working in this school and started
volunteering in community and just
realized I was working with kindergarten
boys who this was a while ago but you
know like we were doing hyper studio and
like these kind of the larger Compact
Disc things laserdisc work and
kindergarten boys were like getting on
their computers and doing the early
versions of PowerPoint and I was working
in community with fifth graders who had
never turned a computer on let alone had
access to do that work and I was like
how are they going to be able to compete
yes like how are we ever going to
address what separates us the divide
just keeps getting larger and larger and
so I think at that moment something
triggered for me because I was trying to
do an activity with a fifth grader that
I had done with my kindergarten boy
and the fifth-grade girl wrote you know
they were it was supposed to be like
five slides kind of an autobiography
thing and like her slide said Winnie the
Pooh is my friend she was fifth grade
and not one word was spelled correctly
not even though and I just was like what
am i doing right how can I do this work
that the world is growing technology is
changing so fast Lee these boys have
she's older than these boys but she's
way further behind than them and every
year they're gonna get more and more
advanced and at that point something
just triggered with me and that was like
that was 15 years ago and something
triggered in me to say like I've got to
do something you've got to do something
to to support this population and so
that became this idea of there are so
many resources and so many opportunities
in this community where I work what does
that look like to translate or to bring
those resources into the community where
I live and how do we begin to realize
and recognize that sometimes folks
really just don't even know how far
behind they are and they don't know what
resources they don't have and so that
became okay well even if I get the
resources to her what does that do for
the teachers or the educators or the
parents like we can't just look at one
piece of it we have to look at the whole
thing and so that was kind of the the
triggering for me and I think the other
piece was that I felt like when I look
back over my experience academic and in
school and out of school like there was
nobody that really in the school day
that was there for me and I didn't do a
lot of after-school programs and I was
like I was fortunate to have a support a
family network a community support that
was like the expectation as you go to
college the expectation is you'll be
self-sufficient and when I looked at
some of the other people there the sense
of hopelessness and families or in
community compounded the fact that there
were no resources and we just really
needed a holistic approach
I don't even and I can't even start to
understand what it's like to have a 5th
grader and a kindergartner with fifth
graders behind technologically to the
kindergartner yeah and that's just
because of socioeconomic status right
access to tools and resources access to
mentors that are teaching the programs
and that puts people on completely
different life outcome trajectories yeah
so it's it's the connection to the tool
at a younger age to being able to access
a computer or a little bit of biology
technology whatever it is can they get
access to at a younger age
and can they have mentors around them
can they have a system that fosters
their creativity and their passions at
younger ages I'm really happy that you
brought that up because I don't think we
think about it like that enough
kindergarteners fifth grader and the
fifth grader was actually further behind
technologically than the kindergartner
that really puts it into perspective
because you're like should all fifth
graders be at the certain level of Kobe
ability to use a computer or an ability
to interact with other humans to a level
where they're you know spelling
correctly or using credit grammar or
whatever it may be
Wow I see how that's really pushes you
forward to want to get involved me too
me too
how about the connection to blockchain
technology where can that really help
with social justice I think in a lot of
different ways I was saying I was
thinking about this earlier there's you
know there are a lot of folks who go
through different programs whether it's
mental health programs whether it's
workforce training whether it's
education programs
and sometimes we're not sure what a
certificate means or what they've
actually done but this idea of using it
to you know as this much more evolved in
superior kind of database of sorts
that's actually a way to transfer
information and document information is
huge especially for people that are
trying to prove that they don't they've
done something whether it's they've come
from another state or another country
and they need to prove that they've got
the experience but the other thing that
the two things that I've seen most
recently was people trying to get jobs
one a transgender woman who was
struggling with being able to prove who
they were right in terms of what
experiences they've had where they've
been where they've worked where they've
gone to school and having to document
that as like their information in their
data and having it be attached to them
versus attached to a name or a certain
point in time yeah and then the other
was a young woman who had gone to UC
Berkeley had you know amassed some debt
there and was trying to get a job and
needed to prove that she had gone to UC
Berkeley and could not get the copy of
transcripts until she paid the debt but
wasn't gonna be able to get the job if
she didn't prove that she had been to
school and so these two institutions
being able to talk to them each other
and like what that looks like and how
that impacts people's ability to move
forward is so screwed up right both of
those scenarios are screwed up but
especially what I can't get my
transcript to get a job to pay off my
debt until I pay my debt like I know
that doesn't make any sense that we we
needed we need to actually have logical
conversations about student debt because
right now it's not quite logical enough
we're just fondling kids into the
education system throwing them and 200k
with a debt and saying good luck have
fun when you get out of here and it's
it's that's horrendous and so is
people's identity being tied to you know
different
different names if they transition in
some way if they change their name in
some way all of a sudden that data about
them it can be more difficult to go back
and access and find so having an
immutable digital ledger is
decentralized is very helpful for
keeping all this data about ourselves
helping us get work helping us actually
I heard this when you guys were talking
on stage a little bit ago I never
thought about the importance of
retention of land I've been we've been
talking about it a lot the retention of
land but I never thought about it in
terms of like 1776 until 2018 because
there were so many people that were
kicked out of the land that they had for
due to manifest destiny it's been
happening for the long since
civilization started with its manifest
destiny happening but now this
technology is in place so that so at
least moving forward now there's no
people can't disappear in their land
we'll just be taken by the ones with
guns no I think that that to me like
when I think about the impact of
Redevelopment Agency or even you know
like the Native Americans and like whose
land is it and who was here first or
some of that I think that there's some
benefit to this notion of like how are
we tracking things and who you know like
there's even with the prospects right
like the prospectors back during the
49ers and the gold rush and like who got
where first and who discovered the gold
first and I think that there's some
level of intellectual property more and
more that it'll be interesting to see
how this all plays out because I think
about when a lot of the tech boom and
even as people in other industries are
doing things now and sometimes your boss
will say to you intellectual property
anything that you create on my time is
is it the organization or the business
owns it and how does that play out and
and I think there's some hope for as we
move forward in the future that people
get paid for the work that they do and
that other folks don't get to co-opt it
because
where they were when they created it and
if nothing else you at least get credit
for the fact that you created it yeah so
I think that there's room for that
because what has happened what we see
with artists and if we think about it in
terms of the the 60s and the 70s when
music and there was this confusion about
like whether the artists created the
music or whether the label created the
music and folks that got played out of
their royalties and what we look at what
happened with stack records and other
places that kind of went out of business
because they couldn't really prove who
was doing what or there was all these
disputes about where the money should go
yeah and all of these artists that are
now broke because they never got the
money that they were due from the work
that they did with the intellectual
property it becomes a conversation about
how does we how do we keep that
decentralized digital ledger and then
how do we also provide the artists of
creator with their share of the rent
profits as well as the ledger seeing
where the where money's going where the
sales are and I think it helps a lot
with us moving forward to have something
that's more transparent moving forward
for land for ownership of IP ok a couple
quick questions that we usually ask on
the show one of the questions is about
wealth inequality and globalization so
as we see you know everyone at the
bottom is slowly coming up from
socio-economic variables going on in the
middle and of socio-economic speciation
maybe and how related to globalism are
we going to be able to handle that as
certain places our focus on geopolitical
leadership while others are focused
maybe I'm more that we are one mentality
right it's interesting we I've got
The Economist Derek Hamilton from new
school who's been doing a lot of work
around the federal jobs guarantee and
baby bonds and he wrote an article for
The Guardian called Trump race still
Trump's race mm-hmm
race still Trump's income right then
this idea of the wealth divide and what
we're having and so we're trying to have
more conversations because I feel like
there is a disconnect in these
conversations from the folks in the
middle and kind of on the lower
socioeconomic economic status like we're
really having San Francisco is losing
its middle class by most accounts right
like it's becoming this city of the
extremely wealthy or the really poor and
that the middle class is being forced
out and yet nobody's really having the
conversations like we're having the
protest against the really rich and they
were advocating for the really poor and
the people in the middle are being lost
and it's a hard conversation to have
because in San Francisco the people in
the middle are like a hundred thousand
to two hundred thousand dollars and so
for folks outside of that that's like
you know outside of the Bay Area that's
like wow that's a lot of money what do
you mean that's middle income and I
think it's hard sometimes to talk about
the folks in the middle we are losing
the middle class and we're not having
deep enough conversations about it and
we don't really know what that looks
like I think that there's a lot of
conversation around nation and how
that's going to impact the lower wage
earners and whether that's going to help
bring them up but as the lower wage
earners come up and as we do more
automation the people that have invested
in that continue to increase their their
profits and then the globalization piece
like how does this all impact you know
especially now what we see going on with
the tariffs and everything else back and
forth like what does this mean in terms
of the developing and creating work here
but then also in terms of service
delivery that's happening outside and so
becoming we are one we're already
becoming so divided and just day to day
conversation it's really hard I mean
we've had to have
difficult conversations about
immigration and certain communities of
color where they're like does that mean
that you've forgotten about us if we
talk about like as we bring people in or
as we talk about how do we support
immigrants what does that mean about the
folks who are living here and does that
mean that you're forgetting about us and
if they if we talk about middle-income
without talking about the layers of
immigration status or whether you're a
person of color or geographic region
like those things so just I you know
it's my roundabout way of saying I don't
I don't know that those conversations
are easy to have and I don't know how
we're gonna actually move them forward
because people are so divided on them
it's used to be the most pressing issues
that societies facing right now is
figuring out how to work together and
how to deal with all the exponential
technology that's happening and how it's
gonna be affecting us and if we don't
quickly become a very good parent to all
these technologies than the child of
this technology that are being born are
going to be reflective of who we are and
we don't really treat each other that
well right now
yeah we were just talking a mocha last
night and the way to a really
interesting way to look at it is if
there's a single tweet that sent out by
Trump or whatever they I doesn't really
care as much about that as when it looks
at the 30,000 replies to that tweet that
are all hate speech and all this kind of
stuff ins can be like oh great this is
how I will learn yeah wonderful right
it's funny we just had an election here
in San Francisco and the mayor elect
that won't take office until July and I
was just surprised how much like
negativity came out of just the like the
person isn't even serving as mayor yet
there was a lot of native de belem and
breat already yeah yeah and so I've seen
some people who said I've shut their
social media down
cuz they're like they just couldn't
believe that it already was so negative
and she's not even in office yet they're
like can we just at least celebrate that
we have elected the first
african-american woman yeah to be the
mayor they're like can we just celebrate
that before we talk about how horrible
she is because we don't know that she's
horrible yes he hasn't even totally job
yet but it's so just to your point this
idea of the responses and the replies
and sometimes it's not even - anything
that's happened yet do you believe that
we are alone in the cosmos do I believe
you know this this I have to tell you
lately I kind of stay up wondering about
things like that and I'm like you're
thinking too much because it's like I
wonder if there are other people like or
individuals or being sitting around
wondering what's going on and planet
Earth yeah I and then I also go back to
this idea that you know we're all
created by some other being right like
that technology its advanced somewhere
else and that they're watching us and
going gosh we made a mistake yeah I have
these moments if I maybe watch too many
sci-fi movies and that I'm waiting for
the ship to come back and take you know
all the folks who follow the rules and
leave the rest really fun thought
experiments they stretch our
imaginations and our creative potential
our understanding of the way things work
do you think we're in a simulation that
has like a couple of times I've kind of
been like you know maybe that and then I
go back and forth over whether this is
like the reincarnation piece right and
whether all of those things scare me and
I have to stop thinking about it cuz I'm
like I don't know if I want to come back
as a bug cuz I'm so scared of bugs and
maybe I haven't been nice to bugs so I
mean there are all these different
things when mine goes off on a tangent
and so the simulation kind of scares me
because that I'm like
if anybody wants to be me right there
it's just all my mind goes all these
places that I'm like maybe I don't want
to do that but I'm often always thinking
like if somebody watching you know like
with all the new like technology and the
TV shows and the movies that basically
show like every time you walk out of a
building somebody can see you and every
time I have for that reason I don't have
Alexa I don't like to use Siri I'm like
always afraid that somebody still they
have intelligent classroom monitoring
systems in China now it's just watching
a video about it last night just looking
at all the kids in the classrooms
counting their attendance watching their
facial expressions watching off and they
raised their hand seeing how much
they're paying attention analyzing their
scores all of that and that is
straight-up mind-blowing that that's
already happening so yeah because when I
was in school and that was literally ten
years ago I was still in high school ten
years ago when they were reading our KD
sake on because they didn't know how to
say my name and I'd be like here right
yeah when that happened I never once
thought that ten years down the line
we'd have intelligent classroom
monitoring systems that seemed facial
recognition of whether I'm in the class
or not I don't think anybody in our high
school was thinking about that and now
it's up to us to teach high school kids
around the world that that is happening
that way they gain a better
understanding of the world that they
live in and the world that we're
entering and how to really figure things
out because it's looking like a lot of
it's becoming very complicated and very
big brother' esque and big sister asked
last question is what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world so I
would I'm a mom my son just finished his
freshman year
of college and I would say like the
immediate thing like the first thing
that came to my head is his success like
that's the most beautiful thing like
that's the thing that brings me the most
joy right and then beyond that is like
the the people that I've worked with
when people find success as they define
it not as we define it like that's a
beautiful thing because what success
comes a level of pride and a level of
joy internally that exudes and people
see that so that is a beautiful thing
yeah
I'm imagining your son actually focused
on his success and happiness in college
versus me I got kicked out of the
dormitories after my freshman well I
joked that you know I got lucky that he
you know had some challenging times and
different things that so he spent a lot
of time in the library and I'm like I
don't know next year he'll be in a he'll
be room a ting he'll have a roommate
that's a friend so I'm like we'll see
but I think for me it's the success not
necessarily academically and this is
what he and I have talked about yeah
but the success of being able to walk
into a room and be confident in who you
are exactly and speak your truth and so
I've never been big on grades or that
stuff hasn't mattered to me as much as
are you okay with you yeah right so if
you're okay with who you are if let's go
and at this time life is good
yeah exactly and how does one go about
the journey of being able to find out
that essence about themselves and then
carrier on that confidence everywhere
they go cuz that's a hard thing I think
that those have been the those are the
times that hurt me the most when he's
struggling with who he is or with a
decision and how to move forward from
that so that those have been like my
biggest pain points when I look no I
can't do that for him he has to do it
himself yeah he does it it's a sweet day
I guess Cheryl thank you so much for
coming onto the show we really
appreciate you thank you and we learned
a lot we have a lot to still do about
social justice providing these tools in
opportune
two more kids around the world and
getting them actualized at younger ages
and being able to leverage technologies
like blockchain in order to help augment
the way that we build our future so
thank you thank you thank you everyone
for tuning in if you guys had a good
time make sure to comment below with
your thoughts make sure to take this
content and go create with it don't just
consume it but go make something go make
a video go write something about it or
share it with other people just two
people go and talk to two other people
about what you learned today and they'll
go tell to people and all of a sudden
we'll have a nice little movement
rolling subscribe join the family drain
us on patreon so you can continue coming
to cool places like boxing for social
justice getting these interviews and
showing you this content thank you
everyone and we'll see you soon
peace
you